good morning Saturday morning just woke
up like I had to even say that um and I
want to show you our backyard progress
so not too much has changed since the
last time we showed it to you other than
the fact that it is about 80% filled now
and that's very exciting
news cuz look at
this she's getting fill
adjust adjust there we go and the dogs
have been
loving playing in this thing I have to
keep them away from it or else they get
in and they're drenched and as you know
or maybe you don't we do have a doggy
door so I'm kind of hoping that they're
scared to get in the pool on their
own so that I can kind of
control the water that comes into my
nose CU I really just don't want to wake
up one night or one morning and then
have everything be covered in mud and
like my furniture just absolutely ruined
because of all the water that they
brought in so I'm hoping that their like
percept depth perception gets
with a little bit once the water is
filled up to the waterline and they're
like wait where is Solid Ground here but
then they also do want him to swim with
us so it's like what do you want Gio
what do you want make up your freaking
mind I know no just welcome to my life
I'm a
mess I'm watching you I know what you
want to
do okay so Papa's in California so that
means today it's uh mama and tiga day
we're going to go get breakfast where
are we going to get breakfast at um I
forgot the rest Egg Works Egg Works and
why do you like going to Egg Works cuz
cuz of the bre bread what kind of bread
the banana bread oh yeah baby okay and
then tell me about your outfit who
dressed you today myself yeah okay what
are you wearing um a jacket a keychain a
shirt shorts and socks and shoes yeah
and a hat ooh Why did you want to dress
with a
hat and and today is going to be 100°
how come we wanted to put on a jacket
just be does it be H oh okay super
handsome okay mission accomplished your
handsome boy let's go
eat so taica got a booster
seat yeah look at him so now he's super
tall how old are you right
now you're seven yeah you look seven so
T is watching my phone he's watching
kids YouTube and I'm going to read I'm
reading Throne of gooss I just finished
the um aatar if you know you know I
finished that whole series and I
absolutely love it and I jumped straight
I didn't want to leave the Sarah and
mass I mean J Mass world I didn't want
to leave it
m you clicked on
something um so because I didn't want to
leave it I wanted to read all her Series
so I'm reading class and I think I'm on
book three and I just can't get into it
I'm like 50% into this
one
and yeah I'm just not it's not picking
up for me yet but I'll I'm going to
stick it through this far what whoa
you're like a balancing
monkey monkey
dude it's
here your muffin how are you
hey muffin you're going to smell wait do
you keep the do you keep orange juice in
your mouth is it in your mouth still
monkey you spilled
[Applause]
it all right all right
she you guys have to see this
dog he's so cool look at
him that's amazing look at
him
look at
me that's cute I'm dying right
now obviously we're back home but yeah
ta is playing I mean this water is
barely
treated um it's still getting filled up
I think we're about like 90% there but M
look at
her oh no it's going to be a problem for
sure I think either I'm going to have to
leave them outside or leave them in all
night cuz I can't have this and it's
perfect cuz if it's hot out here
okay look at that
monkey I think it's cold look at his
face and look at how Cooper treats
her look at that it's just biting her
neck throw his ass in the pool Mia throw
his ass in the pool Mia look at that guy
drenched I think I'm going have to leave
all three of them out owow
Cooper get them back Mia you're letting
yourself get him you get
him I'm watching you you little
creep you mean guy not a creep you
little bully is what I meant to
say okay so I've put tiger to bed now or
his nap um that's been the only thing
that's been helping him not have any
seizures right now he's going on almost
11 months so once he's a year off
seizures or a year without seizures then
we're going to remove him from all
medication and I'm so stoked so we're
going strong there fam okay now what I'm
doing is since ta is sleeping I have
some time to do some like house stuff so
first thing on my come on I'm trying to
like make this look better give me a
second can't oh God I suck with the
camera okay I don't know what I'm doing
friends where we at okay good okay so
I'm trying to get some curtains I'm
going to do the whole Amazon uh cuz I
just want some like sheer curtains so
I'm trying to go online and see how to
measure this cuz I don't know what
the hell I'm doing so I think I'm in it
from ceiling to floor it's about 10 and
1/2 ft so I think I'm going to have it
be like 9 and 1/2 ft um and then this
way is about 14 ft long so yeah I'm
going to add some curtains here I don't
even know if I'm to run it right um I
think I might add like a half Rod like a
little mini rod or
something maybe on this side so it gives
it this dramatic
effect um and then I'm going to get some
here and some in my room but I just
don't know what I'm doing so so so far
I've taken the measurements and even
that was freaking hard
like to get the measuring tape and pull
it out to the point where it's taller
than you and
then to have it not bend on you I see
the professionals that know how to like
install or like handymen and they
just like throw it up and stays like
erect I'm like how how do you do that
how do you do it from like like it
doesn't fold like they can make it touch
the ceiling and I'm like H how do you do
that anyway
so that's kind of what I'm trying to
battle right now I'm trying to figure
that
out monkey yes where are we going to a
mon trck place yes on a whim one of my
girlfriends was like uh I asked her I'm
like hey what are you what are you doing
tonight she goes oh I'm going to go
watch monster trucks and I'm like what
where so she gave me the tickets uh she
gave me the link to buy tickets and I
was like T do you want to go and Tao was
like yeah so now we're going on a whim
no I've never been ta's never been so
we're all going to find out what it's
all about today you have a girlfriend a
friend that's a girl
yes oh time like like a
girlfriend like a romantic girlfriend
yeah like like a girlfriend that wants
to marry a boyfriend no no no a friend
that's a girl you call her a
girlfriend oh
that you're you're Papa's girlfriend I'm
Papa's wife your Papa's girlfriend but
be his girl girlfriend correct then
covers your boyfriend yep correct covers
your wife and covers your husband and
and and you are his wife okay I got to
drive and peace so we are inside right
now and it sounds crazy T are you
excited
yeah what's you look at that it's the
last TR to compete all right let's go
find our seat my favorit It's the Great
Clips two wheel skills challenge this is
the ultimate to D two wheels in this
competition now this is the very first
time mamp fans are going to be scoring
at judgeszone.com so I want you to have
your smartphones and devices handy the
drivers are counting on you to score
accurately and fairly for
the here we
[Applause]
go
w
[Music]
put your hands together for J Suza in
Earth Shaker a Qui CL scoring is open
for the first time in
today on
Jud
okay you think she's going to do good
here we
go
W go
I don't
know
w b
moner my IP oh you should have brought
your iPad so you can record it I'll give
you my phone you can record on my
[Applause]
phone
the one look
[Applause]
watch W wo w w w w w my God
W that's
crazy look
[Applause]
look oh my
god oh no oh no oh
no
[Applause]
oh that was
crazy he broke
it
[Applause]
[Music]
oh wait wait wait that's not a
video
w w w
w
[Applause]
what oh my gosh he's in that black and
green ring machine give it up for Tyler
VGA green
sticker Las Vegas don't forget to subit
your score the judges
zone.com maintaining control is one of
the judging criteria I don't know while
Vegas rolling over doesn't look like
maintaining control so make sure you
keep into consideration when you're
scoring at judges zone.com but the first
move right here Tyler Mania was
incredibly impressive
a walking up bringing it down a nice job
see how they pick him up now remember
your score to
beat is Mike christon and Vendetta with
an
8749 and the score for another minuta
and brave Digger
is
yeah you areon that's a pretty good
vagous number
9777 leader news score meet it's
probably the highest score of the week
and we're going to look at leader board
right now we're going to see where our
drivers are shaping up vett sitting at
second
[Applause]
place by m
aesome
6.9 okay back home kind of came in a
rush um cuz it was like 9:40 when I got
here and ta's bed when he takes or
bedtime when he takes a nap we like to
get him in like by 9 so 9:40 was really
really really push it um but no we're
home he's sleeping now the dogs are
sleeping
and now we officially have a freaking
pool so when we left it was about 95%
filled and now my friends now it is 100%
fil and look at how stunning she
looks look at this beautiful
and I'm so happy with the color we
picked I can't remember what color
exactly we picked but I know we didn't
get pebbletech and it's like this rough
like bumpy surface we had that in our
last pool and it is so sorry whoa um
hello it is so painful so this time
around we opted not to get pebbletech
and we have a smooth surface uh kept it
white with just tint
like little hints of blue to give it
that like very Mediterranean feel CU
that's exactly what I'm going for we're
trying to accomplish here and I think we
did a damn good job it's like this
beautiful
Aqua
Clean look I love it so much it is
perfect I think next week we are getting
our turf installed unfortunately in
Nevada you're not allowed to have grass
in your backyard because they're trying
to conserve water because I guess the
whole planet's Running Out of Water some
um being exaggerated there but so
yeah the Landscaping starts next week
for the rest of this month we're just
wrapping it all
up so I think in about a month we are
ready to rock and ready to enjoy our
beautiful backyard in our forever home
I'm just kidding no I really don't want
to move anymore
but you never know nothing is forever
right but so far no plans I want to stay
here for a bit absolutely love
Vegas love Summerland
specifically it's been wonderful here so
yeah coming together nicely our weird
little backyard
idea I know I'm
crazy but I like it okay I'm going to go
inside and join my
pups oh and I never moved forward past
the measurements for
my for my
curtains we'll get there I'm not going
anywhere if it takes me 5 years to
finally complete my house then it
takes me 5 years I literally still have
boxes everywhere that I haven't unpacked
so
we'll get there when we'll get there for
now just
grateful to be alive be in good health
have family
friends everyone around me that loves
and supports me so I have nothing to
complain about that's all that
ultimately matters and look at these
guys these guys are the best you're the
best you're the
best okay thank you guys so much for
watching
see you guys
tomorrow